if your world was full of infected blood
sucking zombies what would you do
everyone you love has barricaded
themselves within walled city stations
in order to survive and it's only a
matter of time until the zombies break
in and destroy everything i'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the cabernet
zombies in cabaneri of the iron fortress
this kid here has no idea that he is
about to turn into the one thing he
hates most a cabernet zombie ikuma is a
brilliant inventor living inside the
walled station of hinamoto a walled
fortress like many others around the
area that can only be accessed by highly
fortified trains on a day like many
others ikema breezes through his daily
work when a train called the iron
fortress arrives at the station and he
notices a strange girl with pigtails
getting off to greet the ruler of the
city and ikuma interrupts their greeting
because he's way too empathetic for his
own good and tries to protect this dude
who everyone thinks is infected with the
kabane virus and all of his efforts do
nothing more than get him beaten up and
thrown in jail later on that night
though that very same girl with pigtails
bumps into ikuma who we find out is
named mume but the pleasantry is cut
short because just then another train
arrives at the station but something is
not right this train isn't slowing down
it's being controlled by kabane zombies
the city tries to close its gate in time
but it's too late and horror erupts upon
the city of hinamoto okay this is insane
and now everything is about to go to
[ __ ] these stations around the nation
have been active since the company
outbreak when it first began over 20
years ago but now the amount of stations
around the country that are safe and
still active have been dwindling thanks
to increased kabane attacks this means
that the station of hinamoto should have
been all the more careful when it comes
to security around the station if we
noticed the guards at night right before
the train came were already on low alert
and they expected the train to slow down
on their own accord and as a result left
their gate wide open but if my world had
been taken over by cabinet zombies i
frankly wouldn't trust [ __ ] let alone
the brakes of a trained conductor these
guards or more importantly this city
station should have had stricter
security measures like for starters they
should have had all trains come to a
complete and full stop right before
they're about to cross the bridge gate
by doing this they could have prevented
this incident from happening to begin
with by having a policy that all trains
will be fired upon if the train does not
come to a complete stop prior to
crossing the bridge gate and have the
train thoroughly inspected and everyone
on board inspected before allowed inside
and then have everything looked over
again before letting them into the
actual city now even with the gate
closed this train could have still
crashed through it but the fact that
they didn't plan for any of this only
goes to show you whose fault all of this
really is we should probably fire those
guards the train crashes into the walled
city station and thousands of cabinet
zombies are flung into the populated
streets and that's when the horror
begins left and right men women and even
little children are getting eaten alive
by the kabane ikuma breaks out of jail
and runs back to his lab to get his
modified piercing cannon that he created
specifically to puncture the company's
metal cage around its heart but in the
meanwhile terror continues to reign
supreme and everyone anyone ever knew
gets devoured as the whole city gets
torn apart it's every man for himself
elsewhere the ruler of the city leaves
his only daughter while he tries to
clear a pathway to the only escape left
within the city the iron fortress itself
little does he realize that he'll never
get there alive on the way while running
back to his house ikuma lures in this
cabinet zombie on purpose in order to
finally test out his modified piercing
cannon and see if it really will pierce
the metal cage around a cabinet's
glowing heart a cabinet's only weakness
the cabinet lunges and he fires
discovering that it works that this is a
lethal weapon that will kill these
undead bastards but genius comes at a
price because just as this happens he
discovers his worst fear he's been
bitten the virus begins to spread
throughout his body and ikema quickly
tries to save himself by tightening a
collar around his neck squeezing the air
right out of him including the virus and
he manages to stop the virus from
infecting his brain retaining control of
his body and his mind in the process
elsewhere the city holds up in one spot
as they wait for their fearless leader
this guy who is actually now dead to try
and clear an escape route to the train
but mumei just arriving on the scene
grows tired of waiting and decides to
clear the route herself unleashing more
hell upon these combinate than anyone
has ever seen before destroying these
monsters with nearly inhuman speed and
skill allowing all these people to
finally reach the train to board and get
out of there including ikuma who on the
way meets up with his best friend takumi
as they sneak onto the train but it just
isn't his day as he gets discovered
while fighting this kabane that he too
is one of them showing off a glowing
golden heart upon his chest forcing this
guy named kurusu to promptly take him
out but they don't have time to mourn as
the bridge out of the city gets jammed
right as more and more carbonate arrive
on top of the train everyone on the
train prepares for hell to be unleashed
but then they noticed the most insane
thing happening outside it's ikuma alive
and human killing kabane after kabane
clearing the track of stragglers and
unjamming the bridge setting the train
free holy crap this is a huge deal now
with viruses in general it's not
uncommon for some people to become
infected with a virus only to have their
immune system spontaneously clear up the
virus from their system keeping them
from developing the actual virus now
judging from what we can see we don't
know the full situation yet ikuma may be
somewhat asymptomatic since he's clearly
not acting like a cabernet zombie or if
his immune system may truly be resistant
to this outbreak now judging from the
time period i doubt they have access to
such gene editing technologies like we
do today like crispr technology to
enable geneticists to find a way to
perform and manipulate the genetics of
e-commerce in the hopes of finding a
cure but still ecomo could be seriously
useful to them sent the outbreak 20
years prior literally not one person has
been found to have an immunity in any
sense to this virus which makes ikuma an
incredibly rare fight i can't even
emphasize how much if princess ima has
any sense she'll tell kurusu and his
lackeys to grab ikema and lock him up
till they can study him better because
it's doubtful that they'll end up
killing the entirety of the cabinet
population ever which means their best
bet is finding a cure to this horrifying
disease because just like an event that
happened in 1994 when doctors found a
man named steven krohn who had been
exposed to numerous hiv-positive
partners but was found to have no signs
of hiv infection whatsoever resistance
in any sense of the word to a pathogen
is rarely as simple as one mutation made
in the body rather there may be several
genes and proteins at work that confer
resistance meaning finding a cure with
ikuma in their custody will be hard
enough and without him well they may
never get another chance like this again
takami then throws ikuma a lifeline
literally but iguma refuses to grab it
wanting to die rather than be the thing
he hates most but mumei is less of a
whiner than this kid is and swoops in to
save the day and ikuma aiding takumi and
rescuing his best friend but back on the
train kurusu still doesn't trust ikuma
so mumei helps him out by revealing the
most simultaneously awesome and
horrifying thing ever she reveals to
everyone that she too has a glowing
heart that they're not human nor
combinate but something in between
calling her an ikuma a kabaneri but
kurusu doesn't care and isn't trusting
either of them until princess ayame
eases the tension by permitting the two
kabaneri to stay in the boiler room for
the rest of the trip and during the long
ride it is here that we find out that
mummy's power comes at a price and that
after heavy battles she passes out due
to exhaustion surprising ikema she asks
him to be her shield when she passes out
and to act as her protector during her
weakest moments and she begins training
him to become an actually useful
kabaneri and to prepare him for what's
to come later on however training is cut
short as mume senses an infected person
on board the train forcing her to go
looking and in the process gets caught
by kurusu again and upsetting princess
ayame suddenly princess ayame gets word
that the train needs to stop a bit for
repairs and she decides to hold a vigil
for those lost at hinamoto as night
begins on the frail group of humans the
villagers decide to take action and get
rid of mume and ikuma but thanks to
ikema's good boy nature he manages to
convince princess ayame that he's not
the bloodthirsty bastard that everyone
thinks he is and just then he passes out
why because his carbonary body needs
blood to survive just then right outside
mumei finds the infected cabinet that
she was searching for a pregnant woman
and she plunges her sword deep into her
sternum right in front of all of the
horrified little children showing us
that no one not even unborn babies are
safe from this deadly virus okay they
just literally escaped hell itself and
now they're acting like they're clear of
it when in fact it's the complete
opposite they're now exposed and
vulnerable and right within cabernet
territory let's not forget we are not
behind the safety compounds of no
station anymore were literally in the
cabinet's backyard and they could attack
us at any point they're all over the
place which means we should seriously be
thinking about how to not die rather
than how to honor our fallen comrades
not to mention the iron fortress is not
in tip-top shape right now and is
currently inoperable at least until the
engineers repair it so we literally have
no escape route if [ __ ] hits the fan
princess i am a royally screwed up this
time around and so did her protector
kurusu he especially as a trained
soldier should have explicitly told her
that stopping to create a fire for a
vigil was a bad idea and we don't
exactly know how good the cabinet's
eyesight is but i'm guessing that their
sweet glowing eyes and superiority to us
in almost every single physical way
aside from intelligence means that they
can probably see a fire in the middle of
the night without any obstructions a
healthy but average vision could see a
candle flame from as far as 1.6 miles or
from a higher vantage point that same
person might be able to identify objects
from dozens of miles away and that's
just regular all-human vision they had
no business lighting a flame as big as
they did rather everyone should have
remained inside the safety of the train
while the engineers repaired the iron
fortress this would also have allowed
for less variables and time spent
getting back on to the train if the
cabinet were inevitably spotted from
afar however i'm not a monster which
means if we had to light a fire for our
dear old fallen comrades i would have at
the very least taken some precautionary
measures when it came to creating a
flame how about one person lighting a
candle in honor of all of the fallen
deaths and then we blow it out and then
get back on the train the public is
horrified at what moomay has just done
but they suddenly hear the piercing
screams of their very dear princess
sounding off from within the train it's
ikuma and he's about to kill the
princess but suddenly kuruzu comes out
of nowhere and knocks him off of the
princess just when he was so close to
eating her brains the blow from kurusu
knocked some sense back into ikuma who
had no idea just what he was about to do
kurusu begins to freak the hell out and
aim his rifle right towards ikoma's face
but all of a sudden mumei busts in with
the worst news of all the cabinet have
found them and they are on their way
here terrified people then begin to
frantically scramble to get back on
board the train as even the engineers
abandoned fixing the train now in favor
of starting the engine and getting the
hell out of here but the tension and
stress isn't over yet because the
passengers of the train begin to resent
lady ayame thinking that she isn't fit
to be in charge and stripper of her
power and they decide to lock up the
rest of the kabaneri on board along with
forcing the iron fortress to make a
change of course on their way to the
town of konguku by taking the faster and
way more dangerous course through the
mountains later on as the train reaches
the sinister mountains the horrors that
await them there are finally unveiled
and it couldn't be more terrifying
hundreds of cabernet then begin to fall
onto the roof of the train along with an
even more rare and even deadlier breed
of cabernet known as the wazatori or
lerner cabanese which are samurai turned
cabene who retained their warrior skills
from when they were alive okay we are in
some serious [ __ ] right now if you
thought the average old cabernet was
dangerous wait till you come face to
face with one of these this cabernet is
one who has lived long enough to gain
proficiency with a specific set of
skills from their time as a human enough
to retain some or most of its muscle
memory in its cabinet form and for all
of you non-gym bros out there i'm not
one of them though sorry muscle memory
simply is the form of procedural memory
that involves strengthening a specific
motor task into memory through
repetition this is synonymous with motor
learning that even if you stopped
working out for ages once you got your
ass back in the gym all your gains from
the past would come back at an
exponential rate which means even if
these wazitory cabernet took a break
from handling a sword you can bet your
ass that their sword skills are still as
sharp as ever or at least it won't take
long for them even in cabernet form to
get back to their full deadly potential
which means we need to be extra careful
with them but it's not all bad their
swords are still just regular old swords
it's not like they're made from
adamantium or anything like that and
their physiology and organ structure is
still the same as other regular cabinet
which means the safest and most
effective way to beat them will be
through the use of attrition they need
to overpower it and keep their distance
concentrating their firepower through
the use of overwhelming force to
hopefully bring this thing down
eventually i'd also forget about every
single civilian that were on the train
carts that the wazitori came through
because they're probably already dead
and i would mobilize every single human
capable of handling a firearm and fill a
single train cart full of every soldier
i can and then i would unload everything
that we've got into this cabinet volley
fire style like caged rats terrified
civilians get horrifically slaughtered
as the wazitore cabernet devour each
cart they go through until lady ayame
grows some metaphorical balls and
finally decides to confront the
horrifying kabane head on along with
kurusu and his crew and they slay dozens
of kabane and the corpses pile up
elsewhere ikema and mumei decide to help
defend the train and they break out of
their cart and iguama darts on top of
the train with mumei and head to the
front with mume's help ikema takes out
kabaneri one by one clearing the top of
the train but all of a sudden like
clockwork moomae's strength suddenly
disappears and she collapses from
exhaustion forcing ikema to fight at the
wazitori kabane on his own getting near
the front of the cart ekma sees the
kabane zombie down below with the
princess and he begs the humans for some
blood in order to regain his strength
and so princess ayame steps up and
allows ikuma to take her blood allowing
him to regain his full strength and kick
this wazitory cabernet's ass right off
the train showing everybody just how
invaluable these cabineri really are
this also prompts lady ayame to let them
stay on the train indefinitely and
begins to supply them with her own blood
when needed and following her example
everybody else joins in on the blood
drive time passes as the train gets
closer and closer to kongukaku and ikuma
helps the team improve their firearms
and swords with the very tech that he
invented for his piercing cannon
preparing the weapons for the hell that
could come down on them at any moment
just then they arrive at yashiro station
but something is off as it seems empty
or perhaps overrun with kabane which
means that the group must be careful and
to add to their problems a watchtower
has collapsed onto the tracks meaning
there's no way to continue on with their
journey unless they find some way to
remove it and get it done quickly the
survivors of this station warned them of
a black smog that engulfed the entire
station prior just then mumei notices
this old man who signals her to follow
him outside revealing to us that she is
actually on a mission for her brother
lord biba known as the master the old
man then tells me that they think she's
gotten soft and that if she keeps this
up she'll be permanently disposed of he
then warns her to complete her mission
or else elsewhere the team plans to head
to the boiler station to operate the
crane in order to remove the watchtower
from the tracks and they quickly jot
down a slower route to get there but
mumei then suddenly shows up agitated as
hell and she quickly dismisses their
plan opting to instead head straight
there and kill anyone who gets in her
way something seems up with her so ikema
warns her to not head straight into the
boiler station because they don't know
what awaits them but thanks to her
stubbornness moomae shrugs it off not
realizing the mistake she just made okay
ikoma needs to seriously reconsider his
strategy and find out what the hell is
up with mumei because like any good plan
they need to eliminate as many variables
as possible by acknowledging everything
that could go wrong and moomay's
insubordination already makes her a
bigger threat for the entirety of the
group more so than the cabinet are at
this current moment like any good zombie
movie once areas become congested and
full of zombies with the population
around the area dead it's likely that
most zombies would then become dormant
due to the lack of nearby stimuli these
are the most obvious factors in this
plan that already make it painfully
obvious how mume can screw it up for us
if i'm ikuma i would for the good of the
group knock mume out or sedate her and
do whatever i have to to take her out of
this plan entirely and i get it we'll be
more vulnerable with one less carbonary
hybrid but she could cause more problems
than her powers and strength are worth
if she runs in guns blazing and then
needs a nap after 5 minutes at the very
least i would ask her to wait until me
and the rest of the team go and scout
the area first making sure that we're
not walking into some sort of trap and
then i would call mume in the team then
sets off and start their plan arriving
near the boiler room station and exit
the train but mumei is nowhere to be
found and they see her naively running
headfirst into the boiler room station
forcing ikuma to chase after her not
knowing what's behind those doors mumei
then blasts down the door to find a
terrifying horde of kabane but she
continues to do the usual hum and drum
routine of kicking ass and taking names
and kills every single cabernet in that
room right as ikoma and the rest of the
team arrive ikuma is beyond pissed off
but he doesn't have time for her
[ __ ] and he gets to switching the
lever of the crane but something is not
right and a soldier notices a black
shadow down below the structure slowly
realizing his worst fear that's not a
shadow but a cabinet horde thousands of
them climbing up all thanks to mummy's
rush and guns blazing attitude which
alerted them to their presence the team
then scrambles to finish their job while
the cabinet began to rapidly overrun the
platform and iguma tries desperately to
continue to operate the crane but he
suddenly sees an exhausted mummy get
thrown off the side of the platform
looks like she got exhausted again this
forces ikma to stop lifting the
collapsed structure and he jumps down to
rescue mume forcing the iron fortress to
wait for them to get their act together
all of a sudden a huge eruption occurs
and a dark figure rises in the distance
rivaling that of the iron fortress it's
the black smoke kabane just like the
survivors described it the terrifying
black smoke beast begins to chase after
them the train makes a steep detour by
taking the emergency train line into a
fortified garage nearby but they're not
out of the woods just yet as they
discuss about possibly crashing through
the collapsed watchtower since it's
already been lifted halfway and with
little other choice they blast through
the garage doors hoping to get ahead
before the dispersed smoke cabinet comes
back to chase them elsewhere ecoma
trapped in a tunnel tries to dig out
mume who's pinned down by rocks but just
then he hears a horde of kabane coming
for them so like the goody little
two-shoes that he is whips out his
modified piercing gun and desperately
fights off the kabane eventually blowing
him and the rest of the overpowering
horde up later mumei wakes up to find
the crew of the iron fortress there to
help her and she spots an injured ecoma
in the distance but just then they hear
the penetrating rumbles of the smoke
demon it's back okay hold on don't we
remember when we reached this station
the survivors were already telling us
basically warning us about what took
over this station this black smoke
monster so it shouldn't come as any
surprise that the same monster that the
survivors told us about is the one to
ruin everything this is a case example
of poor listening skills just in general
another name for this ginormous creature
is a fused colony and that's what this
abomination basically is it is a titanic
amalgamation of carbonate with its
signature trait being that it will often
take in humans and carbonate dead or
alive to grow in size and therefore
power now its only weak point is where
its heart is which is actually
controlled by a cabinet from within and
this is where this creature draws its
powers from but let's be honest there's
no way that we can actually defeat this
thing and none of these smartypants have
a clue on how to beat it but what we do
have are the fortified train garages
that this smoke monster earlier couldn't
break into and we know that this giant
beast only appears if we bring enough
attention to ourselves so what i would
do would be to head back into the
fortified garage and wait however long
it takes and i would play with two
options option one send a squad to
operate the crane discreetly and remove
the watch tower this time without
catching the attention of every nearby
cabinet or option two send two squads
out one to remove the watchtower and the
other to distract any carbonate and if
necessary sacrifice themselves in order
for us to survive and aside from that
there's not much more that needs to be
said the gang then runs back to the iron
fortress and gets out of dodge before
the smoke monster has time to assimilate
itself back on the train ikuma
apologizes to the annoyed crew who blame
ikemon for the mess up but they forgive
him all disney fairy tale style cause
that's what bros do shortly after the
gang finally manages to remove the
watchtower into how to defeat the smoke
monster and to make up for her [ __ ]
she volunteers to do the killing and
just as planned the smoke monster
finally comes back to life and charges
after them but with preparations in
place they fire the cannon and blast its
chest wide open revealing the monster's
vulnerable open heart being controlled
by a female kabaneri mumei jumps into
the monster to stab it from within
killing it in epic style imploding upon
itself and flinging mummy out allowing
the train to finally get the hell out of
there the days then pass as the iron
fortress finally arrives at chittori
station a lowly station barely left with
any food or supplies so lady ayame
offers the town some new weaponry
provided by ikema to grease their palms
into letting them resupply the iron
fortress with food and supplies the next
day as the crew wakes up rested they
finally hear the whistle calls of
another incoming train with the famous
lord biba riding it he's a powerful lord
and part of the independent unstoppable
killing force and in a turn of events
turns out that this powerful stud is
none other than the brother of mume
herself but something about him doesn't
sit right with ikuma and he doesn't
trust him one bit lord biba does a meet
and greet with the princess and mumei
informs him that there's another
kabaneri just like her and that his name
is ikema and lord biba licks his lips to
this news princess ayame informs him
that within the day they'll be headed up
to kongukaku but the strangeness
continues as later on the princess
notices that something is off because
lord biba's crew are acting strange
later in the engine room lord biba fixes
his train's engine just as ikuma spots
him and offers to help and it is here
where ikema gets the idea of just what
kind of man this warlord really is he
tells ikuma that he believes that the
weak around the world deserve to die and
that only the strong can survive and
just then another kabane attack occurs
and this time we get a front row seat
into just how lethal and deadly lord
biba and his crew really are as him and
his army take out dozens of kabane with
ease and out with those monsters pops up
the old man himself that this attack was
all a trick to lure lord biba out of the
station to be murdered but the old man
is too slow for his own good and dies by
lord biba's hands who kills him
mercilessly right as ikuma bears witness
to it all something is not right with
lord biba and ecoma should trust his gut
now based on our brief interaction with
lord biba we've already learned his
radical world view on everything which
is completely littered with red flags it
is clear by what he said that this dude
is a total sadistic nut job the weak die
and the strong survive i mean who talks
like that lord biba is a charismatic
young leader whom everyone looks up to
and respects and has a way with the
masses judging from how politically
astute he is with engaging people he is
also ruthlessly deceptive with an
extremist mindset this dude spells
trouble and even though we don't know
everything there is to know about him we
already learned more than enough even if
we asked mumei about her brother it
seems as though he is a lonely guy who
is confused about his sense of identity
withdrawn from his own family as seen by
how mume talks to him and he's
completely fine with violence towards
people and we've just found out about
his extreme worldview and i'm also
willing to bet that this mindset comes
from him harboring his anger towards
something because no one has this insane
of a worldview unless they are either
completely nuts or suffering from past
trauma if i'm ecoma i would seriously
ask mumei everything there is to know
about this guy because not for a second
can we trust him and i would also warn
princess ayame and kurusu about him
because even if there's a slight chance
that i'm right based on his credentials
alone being a certified cabinet killer
this guy spells trouble just then lord
biba's men kill off the high-ranking
members of the station in secret and
biba offers himself to escort princess
ayame and the iron fortress all the way
to kongukaku out of the kindness of his
heart of course so the princess accepts
but feels the same thing that ikuma
feels as well that something is off
about this guy later mumei wakes up in a
pod and this scientist reveals that the
marker on her body is growing and her
brother asks mume for a favor to steal
the master key of the iron fortress from
its owner princess ayame and like the
good little snot that she is mume
accepts to do his bidding leaving just
as we find out that lord biba is even
more of a psychopath than we could ever
realize and we see two men tied up
within his dungeon kabane-filled lair
who turn out to be spies for the shogun
of konguku and who set up the old man to
try and kill him lord biba then
interrogates them even further and finds
out that it was his father lord biba's
actual father who left him to die on the
battlefield ten years ago during a fight
with the cabinet cutting off supplies
for his army and causing thousands of
his men to die as a direct result in
another part of the train mummy eerily
enters the room of the princess and she
asks her for the master key but the
princess knows something is off and
questions her about it suddenly mumei
reveals a blade from her right hand
threatening the princess that she better
do as she says but luck has never more
been on princess aiomae's side as
pink-haired conductor girl overhears the
whole thing and swoops in to save her
entering the room and claiming to
already be in possession of the master
key and she hands it to the eager mummy
whose demeanor suddenly and completely
changes as she happily leaves the
princess's room close call and we later
find out that pink hair conductor girl
simply gave mume a random key in order
to distract her just then takumi busts
in and tells the princess that ikoma has
found some kabane being held right in
lord biba's train cart and they rush off
to find out just what the hell is going
on mumei thanks to her brother realizes
that they gave her the wrong key and now
pissed off and on the orders of her
sinister brother mumei goes out to
prevent ikuma from entering their train
cart distracting ikuma by telling him
the truth itself that they keep the
cabinet in there for research purposes
and that mummy herself chose to become a
kabaneri with the help of her brother
and to not be weak like humans and she
closes the door on a heartbroken and
shocked ecoma later on the iron fortress
arrives at watto station the last stop
before kongokaku but the leader of the
station isn't letting lord biba through
without a talk and while lord biba heads
off to play nice with the leader of the
station ekuma tells everyone the
horrifying truth about the cabernet
being on board the train causing
everyone to be suspicious as hell about
him and even lady ayame and she tells
ikuma to go rescue mume okay now i think
would be the time to snoop around a
little bit on lord bieber's train in
order to find out what the hell his
plans are in certified writing because
at this point we cannot afford to sit
around and wait for lord biba to escort
us to konguku we won't make it we need
to get the hell out of here and warn the
shogun that the master cabinet killer is
planning to pay him a visit aside from
that i would also say screw finding
mumei and use lady aimee to our
advantage by repairing and refueling our
train asap and get out of dodge by
manipulating the princess and her master
key we have all that we need to make a
speedy getaway which means i wouldn't
waste the time trying to save amumei to
keep lord biba's attention away from us
however i would convince the princess to
hand over her master key on the off
chance that she can't make it back
because let's face it she's royalty and
there's probably a reason why lord biba
has stuck so close to her this entire
trip he's up to something and we can
smell it so while she plays her princess
role to distract lord biba i'd use this
time to prepare for our getaway with
everything we need close by and
available because reaching konguku
before lord biba is the only way that we
can realistically save everyone on the
iron fortress princess ayame then goes
to meet with the leader of the city
station with lord biba who no one trusts
due to his known hatred for the
shogunate no one except for this stupid
glasses guy the ruler of the city
station elsewhere naive mummy opens the
gate fully to wato station letting in
lord biba's train thinking everything is
hunky-dory and that was her most tragic
mistake all of a sudden lord biba's
train opens up and reveals thousands of
cabernet along with more cabernet being
led right through the front gate causing
panic and killing everybody shocking
mummy and making her realize that she
was just a little pawn in lord biba's
bigger scheme and at that very same
moment back in the meeting room lord
biba kills glasses guy and his men
saying that this city needs to pay for
the shogunate's mistakes all these years
and even takes princess ayam a hostage
the iron fortress needs princess ayame's
master key in order to start the train
so kurusu goes to rescue her while lord
biba prepares even bigger plans stabbing
this blonde girl with a formula that
turns her into another smoke monster but
with too much power comes insanity and
this chick loses her mind in the process
collapsing and going berserk until lord
biba kills her her purpose has been
fulfilled and lord biba intends to use
another test subject to use when they
reach kong kaku mumei is shocked at all
of this while lord biba calmly states
that they will soon live in a world
where only the strong will survive
showing everyone just how messed up this
guy really is and everything gets even
bleaker cause while kurusu saves
princess ayame but then gets captured
everyone else in this innocent station
including children die and ikuma also
gets captured along with mume with
everyone being captured the train
presses on to kongukaku and we find out
that the prisoners are being forced to
donate their blood for the kabaneri but
ikema begins to make plans to escape
coordinating with his friends as to just
how they'll do it elsewhere lord biba
convinces princess ayami to help him
with his evil plans in exchange for the
safety of her people and in the process
we hear more about how lord biba was
betrayed by his father later that night
ikuma and his friends finally escape and
take over control of their train cart
and slowly take back one train cart at a
time this causes lord biba to ask mumei
to go kill ikema or he'll stop giving
her the kabane antidote meaning she'll
become a kabane zombie but surprisingly
mumei resists and then gets the [ __ ]
kicked out of her because lord biba is
even more horrifying than anyone could
have predicted and even manages to trap
yukoma and his crew revealing that he
predicted ikoma's plans all along and
brutally kills ikuma's best friend
takomi in the process tearing him apart
literally suddenly a brainwashed mummy
shows up to stab ikuma killing him and
he descends into the ocean however the
next day ikema wakes up ashore on the
beach he's alive but traumatized as all
hell thanks to lord biba who on the
train injects brainwashed mume with the
same crazy formula as he did with blonde
girl meaning [ __ ] is about to go down
because word of lord biba's genocide at
wato station finally reaches the shogun
at kongukaku but this shogun is too
cocky for his own dang good and prepares
for what he thinks will be an easy
battle just then however he gets word
that the iron fortress has arrived with
lord biba as their prisoner at the front
gate lord biba and princess ayami exit
the train and this health officer states
that there is a strict three-day
quarantine procedure even for
non-infected people but then suddenly
ignores that rule for lord biba and
princess ayame like a dumbass okay now i
like kong kaku style of quarantine
because here's the thing we need to
watch out for the incubation period
which is the time before the symptoms of
a viral infection appear which can vary
highly depending on the disease in
question from the common cold having an
incubation period of one to three days
to measles having 9 to 12 days and stuff
like the kuru disease having an
incubation period of an astonishing 10
to 13 years now from the looks of things
this virus has an incubation period
somewhat similar to the common cold
lasting at most a couple of days before
transformation although the medical
literature out there does show that
prolonged incubation in viruses is a
thing and that means for starters i
would increase the quararotine procedure
to at least double of what it is now the
kabane virus does take at most a few
days this means that it is possible that
some people could have a delayed
response and also it's possible that
some people's bodies could have a
delayed response depending on how they
got infected whether it was through a
small cut or a large bite and secondly
it is apparent by everyone at kongukaku
that lord biba hates the shogunate which
means i would not let him and princess
aimee through without employing standard
security measures by having a tighter
quarantine procedure and having a good
old regular pat down along with the
confinement of lord biba and his
subordinates i'm just saying if i was
the shogun and my psycho son paid me a
visit whether or not he was in chains
i'd still put him in a prison cell
before paying him a visit this town
knows biba is a psycho and a master of
trickery so the fact that they're being
so chill about letting him visit the
shogun is beyond me and this will cost
them back on the cold sandy beaches of
nowhere scarred ikema hears a russell
and readies his weapon only to find
kurusu popping up looks like he escaped
but unlike ikuma kurosu hasn't given up
and smacked some sense into ikuma and
reveals the most insane thing ever
revealing that there's no way mume could
have missed ikoma's heart which means
she spared him on purpose this means
that the old mume is still in there
somewhere and this lights a fire under
ikuma but then he finds out from his
captured evil scientist that there's no
hope left to save mume once she turns
into the black smoke unless ikema
injects her in the heart with white
plasma ikuma then does the unthinkable
and demands that he be infected with the
black blood that this evil scientist has
on his person this black blood is an
accelerator for the company virus but it
will also enhance all of his powers at
the cost of his sanity but because he's
a man he won't turn into the black smoke
monster just one badass all-powerful
kabaneri with a very very short life
span and so ikema stabs his own chest
and takes off his collar allowing the
full power of the cabinet virus to flow
through his veins making him stronger
than any kabaneri before him meanwhile
back at kongukaku lord biba kneels
before the all-powerful shogunate and
the boss man takes out an old knife from
his son's belongings that he remembers
giving lord biba when he was a child and
so sneaky lord biba plays on his
nostalgia by begging his father the
shogun to kill him with that weapon and
so the shogun agrees readying his knife
he suddenly gets cut by it and he begins
to show signs that he's infected lord
biba then freaks everyone in the room
out by saying that there are other
kabane hiding among the people and even
goes onto the intercom to let the people
of kong gokaku know the same thing that
the cabinet are out among the people
everyone and i mean everyone begin to
freak out and what comes next is an
absolute slaughter because nobody trusts
anybody and to make matters worse lord
biba pulls the same stunt that he did at
iwato station unleashing thousands of
kabane from his train doors allowing the
cabinet to quickly take over the
fortress and countless people get
slaughtered by the company men women and
children while mume as the black smoke
continues to rain havoc across kong
gukaku ikuma and kurusu finally reach
kongukaku and take out kabane after
kabane as they make their way to mumei
with a plan to inject mume with the only
white blood vial in existence meaning
ikuma must give his life for mumes
elsewhere lord biba orders the
evacuation of his troops and his people
as he readies to take care of some
personal matters and he intends to hunt
down ikema himself and lord biba finds
ikema who at the same time also finds
mume prompting their battle over mume's
soul to begin the two warriors then go
at it as battle-hardened lord biba slays
and slashes ikuma down to his knees
proving who the better warrior is until
iguma through sheer will manages to kill
lord biba a now exhausted and almost
lifeless ecommerce forces himself to go
inject the cure into mume reverting her
back to her old self and ikuma passes
out but just then lord biba comes back
from the dead and demands ikuma to
continue to fight him until he gets a
permanent timeout from his little sister
ending his reign of terror once and for
all later as hell continues to reign
upon a ravaged kongkaku lord biba's men
arrive at the iron fortress and make a
deal with princess ayame they'll show
her the way out in exchange for letting
them ride along with her and she agrees
putting an end to the battle between the
two factions that took so many lives as
the iron fortress makes its way out they
collect iguma kurozu and mumei and mume
continually pleads for ikema to come
back to her until he does as we find out
through convenient plot armor that lord
biba ended up slipping ikema the only
other white plasma in existence that he
had on him possibly indicating that in
his last moments lord biba finally
managed to grow a heart but literally
not one person gives this a second
thought as the iron fortress happily
makes its way out of a destroyed
kongukaku with another destroyed city on
their list and them not a step closer to
winning the war against the kabane but
on the plus side all the main heroes
survive except for takami poor poor
takumi but what do you guys think would
you survive cabin area of the iron
fortress let us know down in the
comments below let us know what you like
what you didn't like and as always don't
forget to check out our playlist and our
social media